Hello. This is Six Minute
English from BBC
Learning English. I'm
Neil. And I'm Beth.
"Plastic is fantastic."
This phrase was used a lot
in the 1950s
when mass-produced
plastic items started to become part
of our everyday lives.
The following decades saw a revolution
as plastic became
the most commonly used material
in modern life, found in everything
from cars to furniture to packaging.
Take a quick look around
and you'll soon see how many
everyday items contain plastic.
But now our love
of plastic is being questioned,
mostly thanks to climate change and
pollution caused by single use plastics –
plastic products which are designed
to be used just once
before being thrown away. 11
million tonnes of plastic waste
are dumped into our oceans
every year.
It's believed that
single-use plastics make up 40%
of all plastic pollution
globally. What's more,
it's not just land and water being
polluted - tiny plastic pieces known
as microbeads have even been found
inside the human body
and can be passed from mother
to child through breast milk. And
because plastic comes
from fossil fuels, the process
of making it creates problems
at every stage,
from burning coal, to transportation,
to recycling. In this programme,
we'll be asking: is it
time to live without plastic?
And, as usual,
we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first
I have a question for you, Beth.
One reason why plastic
became so popular is that
it's a very flexible material.
It can be formed
into different shapes,
making it useful for keeping
food fresh, or holding liquid.
Originally, plastic was invented
to replace the decreasing supply
of natural materials like metal, wood
and glass. So which items did plastic
first replace? Was it:
a. snooker balls b. shopping bags
or c. hairbrushes?
Hmm, I guess the
first thing to be made
of plastic was a hairbrush.
OK, Beth, I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme.
Dr Sherri Mason is Professor
of Chemistry at Penn State University
in the US, and a
specialist in plastic pollution.
Her award-winning 2017
research into microplastics
in rivers led to the US Congress
banning microbeads. Here,
she explains the problem
of plastics to BBC
World Service Programme, The
Real Story.
Plastic is synthetic and,
as a consequence of that, nature
doesn't really know
what to do with it.
Like, a paper bag that's sitting
on the side of the road –
it's unsightly, but within weeks
there are organisms in the soil
they can use that paper bag
as a food source, right...
They have evolved
to basically chew up that paper bag
and turn it back into soil,
turn it back into carbon
and nitrogen and oxygen.
But with regard to plastic,
because it is a synthetic material,
you don't have that evolution.
There are some organisms
that can use it as a food source,
but they're few and far between,
especially when you're talking
about water systems, aquatic systems
and the temperatures that exist, and
so they can't really use it as a food
source so plastic doesn't biodegrade...
Plastic is a synthetic material,
meaning that it's made
by combining manmade chemicals,
instead of existing naturally.
Natural materials like paper decay
and harmlessly turn back into soil
– they biodegrade.
But plastic is not like this.
It doesn't decay and get broken down
by microbes and bacteria.
In fact, some plastic-eating microbes
and bacteria do exist,
but these are few and far between,
they're rare –
they don't happen very often.
It is the fact that
plastic doesn't decay
which is responsible for the waste
we see in the environment. Waste
which is often unsightly, meaning ugly
and unpleasant to
look at. Fortunately,
help is at hand.
The plastic-eating microbes
Neil mentioned, especially one called
Rhodococcus ruber,
have been tested by scientists
and seemed capable of breaking down
plastic into its basic components.
What's also needed is an emphasis
on reducing plastic production,
especially packaging
and other single-use products, rather
than simply recycling. Action
like this should help
plastic achieve its original purpose –
to help preserve, not pollute,
our natural resources. And speaking
of the origins of plastic, isn't it
time to reveal the answer
to your question, Neil?
Right. I asked you
which object made of natural materials
was the first to be replaced by plastic?
You said it was a hairbrush which was...
the wrong answer, I'm afraid Beth.
In fact, the first
plastic-moulding machine
was used in 1872
to produce snooker balls.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we have learned from this programme,
starting with single-use plastics –
plastic products which are designed
to be used just once,
before being thrown away.
Microbeads are tiny
plastic particles found in products
like toothpastes and body scrubs,
which can enter and pollute rivers,
seas and the human body.
The adjective
synthetic describes
a non-natural material
made by combining chemicals.
To biodegrade means to decay naturally
in a way that is not harmful
to the environment.
The phrase few and far between
means very rare
or not happening very often.
And finally, if
something is described as unsightly,
it's ugly and unpleasant to look
at. Once again
our six minutes are up.
Join us next time
for more trending topics
and useful vocabulary here
at Six Minute
English. Goodbye for now.
Goodbye!